another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation no dr bride  you cannot have a pet scp we don't care  how many o5 council members agree to it  or if there have been precedents set by  previous cases dr bright has not proven  himself responsible enough to have a pet  scp of any kind we gave him a goldfish  and he promised to keep it alive for a  year he failed we gave him a potted  plant and he promised to take care of  that it lasted a week giving dr bright a  dangerous anomaly to kara4 would be a  huge security risk and giving him a  harmless scp would certainly constitute  animal cruelty and no he absolutely  cannot have scp-999